ça fait tellement longtemps que je vous
ai pas fait ça mais tellement longtemps
que ça me manquait une bonne vieille
vidéo d'astuces avec votre iphone savoir
toutes les astuces tout connaître tout
optimisé parce que peut-être que vous
avez un iphone si vous regardez cette
vidéo si vous n'avez pas ça pourra
peut-être vous intéresser en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on ne connaît pas
toutes les fonctionnalités tellement
l'étendue des possibilités est énorme
chez apple donc on va regarder quelques
bonnes astuces quelques tricks quelques
types que me connaissaient pas forcément
ici j'en ai 9,9 qui sont très cool et je
compte sur vous pour me dire en
commentaire si vous en connaissez doc
lesquels vous connaissiez lesquels vous
ne connaissiez pas est ce que ça vous a
intéressé oui ou non et bien évidemment
dès maintenant lâché moi un gros pouce
vers le haut un gros like regardez cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout ça c'est bien ça
c'est bon ça m'a fait plaisir
et merci à vous alors vous est pris on y
va
[Musique]
première chose il vous faut un iphone si
vous avez un iphone tant mieux c'est
beaucoup plus pratique
ça c'est le mien c'est l'iphone 12
promax la première astuce c'est pour
envoyer les messages les réponses les
plus claires aux personnes qui vous
écris savez des fois quand pour ça des
petits sms on se dit ah mais je lui
réponds je vois un petit message
on voit ici d'être clair quelqu'un que
vous aimez qui vous a bien fait plaisir
quelqu'un vous aimez très très fort et
dense à un petit zoom comme ça hop vous
venez là et vous allez choisir allez un
p'tit choeur sauter deux petites lignes
vous le choisissez ensuite des petits
emoji d'amour votre tête de petites
lignes d utiliser moggi de bisous voilà
comme ça on est pas mal et ensuite vous
venez à elle laissé appuyé ici longtemps
et vous allez dans écran regardez ce que
ça va envoyer au lavage c'est beau et
vous envoyez à la personne que vous
aimez et elle elle le reçoit comme ça
quand il ya de l'amour tout de suite
c'est clair les choses sont claires
c'est quelqu'un qui vous a un petit peu
vexé et bien on va faire ça différemment
vous lui envoyez ça signale d'abord
aussi c'est pas tout à fait le même
amour voulu envoyer une tête qui fait la
tête toujours de cases vous sautez et
vous l'envoyez à l'espèce de porta qui
fait la gueule et l' appui long de la
même manière vous allez sur écran et là
je crois que le message est aussi très
très très clairs garder à qu on envoie
sa part et voilà ce qu'il reçoit voilà
je crois que l'agglo ben sylla pas
compris il est pas très bon
avant de vous montrer notre astuce
invite à venir vous abonner pour tout
savoir sur les bonnes astuces soyez sur
un iphone vous parle de nouveautés
technologiques nous parle de plein de
trucs ça c'est super cool
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge que si
tu veux juste là si les rouges si vous
n'êtes pas abonné actionner la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle à l'organe en
tout cas on connaît pas forcément dans
nos messages lorsqu'on veut écrire à
quelqu'un c'est la question des sondages
vous voulez poser une question à
quelqu'un au lieu de l'envoyer un petit
message en lisant vettel peut faire quoi
soit vous voulez aller plus loin et de
faire des propositions on a une solution
qui est extrêmement cool c'est ça c'est
poule fort imessage vous l'avez là c'est
écrit poule for high med says vous
balancer et là vous commencez à créer
votre petit sondage là vous marqué par
exemple on s'en fout ce soir bon là ce
soir on s'en doute pas mais croyez moi
dès qu'on va pouvoir ressortir ça ça
sera un truc à utiliser et vous pouvez
utiliser
pour des anniversaires vous pouvez
l'utiliser pour aller au sport pour
utiliser pour plein de trucs on s'en
vont ce soir ça c'est la question
ensuite vous allez marquer en club donne
vous mettez un autre adoption
vous allez marquer quoi je sais pas on
va chez mimile ça peut être un pote ou
un bar à vous de voir ou en marque en
saurons ce soir elle un cinéma ça je
suis très sage dans les propositions
bien évidemment vous faites ce que vous
voulez vous avez ça ensuite vous allez
juste en dessous ici sur sanne poule
pour l'envoyer hélas la personne le
reçoit et il paraît riz au tac distribué
elle le reçoit et ensuite elle a plus
qu'à cliquer à l'endroit où elle veut
aller alors par exemple j'en sais rien
moi elle se dit à cette personne je vais
lui en club et peut même choisir vallée
chimie mais il est au cinéma on peut se
faire une soirée très complète et après
elle peut venir là même faire des
petites propositions vous n'êtes pas mal
de possibilités il ya beaucoup de
paramètres ça il vous faut venir
télécharger un petit truc là vous allez
dans l'app store vous cherchez paul-fort
imessage vous le télécharge et
s'installe directement et ça c'est
vraiment hypra cool ah ouais j'ai une
astuce qui aussi très sympa pour la
photo pour la caméra vous savez la photo
sur des usages principal on fait tous
des photos avec nos iphone au lieu
d'aller naviguer dans vidéo directement
et venir appuyer vous perdez du temps
non vous restez sur photos et voulait
s'appuyer vous glisser sur la droite et
axa lance une vidéo
ensuite pouvait faire des photos dans
votre vidéo si vous le souhaitez assez
sympa une petite photo et vous revenez
là pour tournoi photo et lorsque vous
êtes là vous dites assez sympa vitu
faire plein de photos plus faire des
rafales et bien vous prenez vous le dis
c'est là et vous faites des rafales au
tac aux rêves au rafale vos photos vos
vidéos
c'est très facile c'est très pratique
alors il ya des trucs assez sympa sur
tik tok par exemple je vous emmener sur
nos tik tok à moi parce que oui je fais
son tik tok je vous emmène je sais pas
moi sur une deux
mes vidéos tient à nager une vidéo qui
est assez sympa sur tik tok et vous vous
dites à cette vidéo les couilles de
monsieur que vous voudrez bien la
regarder un peu plus tard ont
normalement télécharge pas les vidéos
c'est interdit mais vous donnez petites
astuces qui est très très cool ou cliqué
sur les trois petits points
vous allez ensuite ici la regarder
photos live ça vous créez une photo live
ça vous marque conversion en photos live
vous allez ensuite dans votre
application photo vous avez ce que vous
avez créé ici la voyez ça sert à rien ça
bouge pas c'est pas très rigolo
vous cliquez regarder la justice'' trois
petits points et vous allé jusqu'à
enregistrer comme vidéo à partir de la
photo live en gros ça va venir vous
créez une vidéo est là juste à côté
vous retrouvez une vidéo à partir de ce
que vous avez récupéré de la photo live
alors ici vous avez pas d'audio par
contre il ya des questions droit bien
évidemment mais par contre vous récupéré
pas mal de petites choses
donc s'il voyait trucs qui sont sympas
bien évidemment respecter les questions
de droits d'auteur car c'est très
important mais voyez ça en tout cas
c'est rigolo d'ailleurs dit mon
commentaire ça si vous connaissiez oui
ou non
autre astuce qui est très très cool vous
êtes sur n'importe quel réseau ne pourra
pas un réseau social vous voulez une
musique qui vous plaît vous les
retrouvez vous allez ici dans vos
réglages vous avez dans votre centre de
contrôle dans votre centre de contrôle
vous allez sur reconnaissance des
morceaux vous venez là ajouté ça vous
créez un petit raccourci ici dans votre
centre de contrôle qui vous permettra de
venir écouter la musique et vous dire de
quel morceau il s'agit autre astuce qui
est très sympa vous retrouver comme moi
une vieille photo celle là elle est un
peu pourri je vous le cache pas c'est
une vieille photo que j'avais fait
avec un pur espèce de polaroïd ça
manquait de lumière et le truc est pas
complètement dingue mais si vous voulez
venir se caler une de vos photos vous
êtes cézanne à bwin plutôt qu'il vous
plaît vous voulez bien l'as canet pour
la récupérer et bien vous avez un mode
qui est très facile
au lieu de faire une bouteille votre
iphone qui sera des fois un peu pas
terrible vous laissez ici vous allez sur
note vous faites un appui long vous avez
ici
l'option qui s'appelle scanner un
document vous prenez votre photo vous la
posez en dessous up lui il le reconnaît
et il enregistre directement et regarder
ça c'est quand même vachement bluffant
autre astuce qui est assez rigolote
lorsque vous envoyez des messages voulez
pas vous embêter à écrire des trucs très
très long je vous remercie descamps
d'helmand et compagnie n'ont volé un
truc simple et efficace
là vous allez dans réglages vous allez
ensuite dans général et dans général
vous allez dans clavier jusque là c'est
très simple il vous retrouver ici c'est
petit parti qui s'appelle remplacement
l'expression ça sera en majuscules
bonjour on va se faire un truc un petit
peu cordiales comment allez vous je vais
bien merci
voilà comme ça vous faites les questions
et les réponses histoire de vous montrer
un peu l'idée et vous mettez ici un
petit raccourci très simple vous marquer
juste derrière pour bonjour et vous
enregistrer
ce qui fait que l'on suit lorsque vous
venez envoyé un message par exemple eh
bien vous venez juste taper ici un petit
bjr ça vous le propose ici vous cliquez
paf c'est parti bonjour comment allez
vous je vais bien merci j'en vois c'est
pratique c'est sympa vous ne vous
embêtez pas donc voyez ce truc là c'est
très malin ça vous évite d'envoyer des
tartines de dengue genre et bien
cordialement merci au revoir à demain je
vous embrasse vous mettez les petits
raccourcis il faut s'en souvenir mais ça
j'aime beaucoup je trouve ça extrêmement
mal hein il ya un autre truc assez cool
je vous montre regardez ici par exemple
sur google je cherche des informations
sur le laos respect partir en voyage un
jour au laos
allez savoir je vais sur wikipédia et je
me dira si génial il ya plein de choses
j'ai envie de lire j'ai envie de tout
savoir sur la géographie sur l'histoire
mais là malheureusement j'ai pas le
temps j'ai le bus qui arrivent et je
dois partir où je pars en voiture j'en
sais rien donc ce que je fais ici s'exp
une capture d'écran bouton d'allumage et
boutons de volume sur le haut claque
capture d'écran je clique sur ma capture
d'écran et l'a ensuite c'est là où la
magie opère regarder en rouge et
l'option écran ou pleines pages moi je
vais sur pleine page cela d'enregistrer
ma page en entier une fois que celui-là
je fais ok et je fais en dessous ici il
à enregistrer le pdf dans ce fichier
mais mais par exemple dans ce fichier
j'ai créé un petit dossier ali
j'enregistre ici ensuite je ressors de
là je veux chercher fichier qui est
quelque part par ici je suis dans mon
dossier à lire regarder la gelée ici
j'ai la hausse wikipédia je clique est
là et la magie opère c'est
extraordinaire je retrouve tout garder
je peux lire la partie géographie la
partie histoire en mode hors connexion
parce que ça va créer un pdf en fait et
ça c'est vraiment hypra coup alors il
faut avoir ouvert les autres items sans
quoi ça ne sert à rien du tout c'est
juste un pdf pensé à tout ouvrir pour ni
enregistré que ce soit des recettes de
cuisine peuvent venir enregistrer et
mettre dans un dossier cuisine si vous
voulez des informations des cours tout
ce que vous voulez vous pouvez le faire
en pdf mais ça mais c'est juste génial
d'ailleurs pour ça on blesse un joli
push parce que moi tout ça vraiment hot
et les dernières astuces aujourd'hui
signalent tout ce qui pourrait peut-être
vous sauver la vie et qui est très très
cool on vient ici dans réglages on vient
ensuite dans accessibilité et dans
accessibilité en descend un petit peu et
vous venez juste là dans ce qu'ils
appellent la reconnaissance des sons la
reconnaissance des sons c'est génial que
ça vous permettra notamment aux
personnes qui sont déficients auditifs
d'être alertés grâce à leur smartphone
pour vous cliquez vous l'actionner si
vous choisissez le team son qui va
reconnaître notamment une sirène une
fumée ou un feu même du bruit de feux
pourquoi pas un animal un chien et un
chat qui volent chien boit aussi le chat
miaule il vous le fera savoir pareil si
vous avez un klaxons de voitures vous
êtes dans la rue ça klaxonne du volcan
n'est pas forcément lui à vous alerter
les sonnettes un bruit de porte sur
laquelle on frappe pleurs bébé vous
choisissez vous sélectionnez ce que vous
voulez up la sirène la fumée le feu tout
ça vous revenez en arrière et là vous
serez alerté dès qu'une scie bruit sera
reconnu par votre iphone et ça c'est
génial
voilà donc pour ces quelques astuces que
je voulais vous présenter aujourd'hui en
a 9 ans tous dites moi d'ailleurs vous
si vous les connaissiez si vous les
connaissiez pas si vous voulez qu'on
continue à parler d'astuces pour iphone
fera également des astuces sur android
dites moi si ça vous intéresse
dites moi ce que vous connaissiez et
dites moi si un homme qui vous a plu en
particulier marc m'a bien évidemment
tout ça en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler tech j'envoie des
brokers oui beaucoup d'amour et prenez
soin de vous ciao ciao ciao sa libido